if you look at influencer marketing  there are millions making a hundred  thousand so many of these markets are  winner take all markets on the platform  side what do you mean google facebook  tick tock sorry about on the individual  side on the individual side the long  tail of creators is extremely long it's  winner take all if you define success a  million dollars if you define success  eighty thousand dollars it's astonishing  and i keep telling a lot of my corporate  friends and leaders you're worried about  the great resignation wait till you see  the great never applying in the first  place you've got an entire generation of  kids growing up on roblox tiktok  fortnite who are like i could work at  ibm or vaynermedia or whatever or i can  make 61k doing x y and z i'll keep  building maybe i get to 200k and it is a  blind spot to the establishment at scale  and so what we talk about is these kids  are entitled they're not entitled  they're aware of their options